these buzz around the next season of
Dancing with the Stars is whether or not
Simone biles will try and add a mirror
ball trophy to her collection our senior
news editor Jennifer perils caught up
with all of the gold medal-winning final
5 this morning at the Empire State
Building
I'm hearing you might begin again
superstar that's true well I would love
to but the fall season won't work
because we're just so busy with tour but
if I could do the spring season I would
love to do that have you thought about
who your partner would be um I think uh
Sasha they do with my height so yeah I
think is the one of the shorter ones I
think that would be cool to be with
Sasha
Simone's teammate Ally Raisman knows all
about dancing she competed with Mark
Ballas back in 2013 and we think Simone
and sasha barber could be the perfect
pair she's a petite four foot nine and
sasha is about five foot seven
the real games have made the Golden
Girls household names
they got congratulations tweets from
Taylor Swift and Lady gaga and today
that usher man
lucky me Hollywood here they come
been invited to be on Pretty Little
Liars Gabby Douglas is going to be a
Miss America judge are you gonna be a
tough judge easy judge and Ally got a
date proposal from an NFL player
ally what's up it's cold under a tight
end for the Oakland Raiders it will be a
double date with former Olympian Shaun
Johnson and her husband Andrew East who
is also on the Raiders seems ally is
very appreciative of male athletes
there's just like a lot of cute boys in
the village I'm not touching that
meanwhile there is one thing that the
final five said they'd like to do
together and that is a pair on Saturday
Night Live